c'est ici au service de réanimation des
urgences de l'hôpital rabta au coeur
même de la capitale tunisienne que le
corps médical est sur tous les fronts
pour contenir l arrivée massive des
personnes contaminées ou alors des
personnes suspectées d'être contaminées
par le coronavirus ici en tunisie la
question est de savoir si le corps
médical est équipé en termes de moyens
et en terme de logistique pour faire
face à cet afflux massif de contaminer
pour été très difficultés pour vous s'il
ya une propagation du virus à ses
massifs dans la capitale et dans
l'ensemble du pays
dans tous les cas il faudrait savoir que
tout le monde est dans la même barque
c'est à dire si nous on prend soin et en
ce essaient de se protéger et que
ailleurs ce n'est pas le cas donc la
déferlante va toucher tout le monde donc
il faudrait que ça se prépare aussi bien
ça commence par la personne elle même il
faudrait que elle considère que toute
autre personne peut être donc porteuse
20,1 du virus donc un doigt elle se
protéger et protéger les autres qui sont
les siens de l'improbable pour
propagation mais il faudrait que aussi
bien sur le poteau le personnel soignant
soit de très bien protégé pour ne pas
être lui même un vecteur à l'extérieur
de ce virus
avec plus de 5000 personnels
paramédicaux pour travailler dans les
réanimations et plus de 400 lits
disponibles
la tunisie est pour le moment paraît à
faire face à cette épidémie mondiale
dans le plus grand hôpital de tunis
le docteur abid à magra oui chef service
des urgences et son équipe se prépare à
accueillir davantage de patients une
préparation circuit isolé des autres
urgences nécessaires pour parer au mieux
aux nouveaux cas de kobe 19 dr presque
vous vous les expliquer comment vous
organisez ici dans cet hôpital pour
prendre en charge les malades atteints
du virus
effectivement nous avons commencé à se
préparer depuis deux semaines déjà on
même un peu plus pour tout ce qui est
acquisition de matériels spécifiques et
donc c'est une préparation qui prévoit
un circuit que 8,19 qui est complètement
isolée du circuit habituel du malade
urgents qui qui pourrait arriver dans
notre hôpital
donc c'est un circuit qui complètement
de délocaliser des urgences avec deux
systèmes de pré triage qui sont
installés à l'extérieur
on va repérer août sur le circuit que
vide donc les critères de gravité
pouvoir rapidement orienter les malades
graves sur donc l'endroit dédié pour la
prise en charge des malades graves ou
sur le deuxième prêt triage pour ceux
qui échappent qui n'arrivent pas à ceux
à se localiser convenablement par
rapport aux circuits que vite en valais
pré triés au niveau d'un poste près
triage avancées au niveau des urgences
qui complètement à l'extérieur et de là
on va les orienter sur le circuit
convient donc que nous avons dédié à
l'hôpital pour les médecins et les
infirmiers ou le personnel soignant des
hôpitaux de tunis l'heure est à la prise
en charge des premiers patients infectés
ou suspectées d'être infectées par le
virus qu'on soit en tunisie ou dans le
reste du monde ils sont en première
ligne pour lutter contre cette épidémie
pour le moment avec 54 cas de
contamination un décès une personne
guérie elle les médecins tunisiens ont
déclaré que la situation était sous
contrôle mais si l'épidémie devait et à
être beaucoup plus importante en tunisie
le manque de moyens le manque logistique
pourrait être un problème pour guérir
tous les patients